this is usually the time of year when
audiences are packing movie theaters to
see some of the most anticipated films
hollywood has to offer
but even with most theaters closed there
are still plenty of ways to watch movies
new
and old at home with seemingly limitless
options of what to watch
we asked some acclaimed filmmakers to
offer their suggestions
anna bowden co-director of captain
marvel an executive producer of the fx
mini-series
mrs america kevin smith who rewrote the
rules of independent filmmaking with
clerks
and his jay in silent bob series paul
feig director of bridesmaids an
executive producer of the new hbo series
love life
and ava duvernay director of selma and
the oscar nominated documentary
13th all of them sharing with us the
movies that still make them
laugh cry and reflect on our current
times
[Applause]
i will choose dog day afternoon and i
love the film because
cindy lamet handles issues
in 1977 that we're still dealing with
now
as it relates to class and economic
disparities and the desperation that
people feel
and i love it because it's it talks
about
someone taking action um to regain power
um but one of the things i love so much
about the film is its treatment of
lgbtqia
issues in 1977 at the core of that movie
is that you know the main character is
robbing a bank
to help pay for a reassignment surgery
for his uh partner what's that
we went to the bellevue where you told
us said he was his wife
they were married in a church we're
dealing with trans
issues in 1977 and
when you watch it all the words are
wrong and nothing's politically correct
but it was perfect for the time
i very recently for the first time
watched the ghost and mrs muir
it's just a spectacular movie
it's so romantic that the whole theme of
like you meet
your soul mate but it's somebody who was
in a different time period this was just
a really
really beautiful movie i mean gene
tierney's gorgeous
and rex harrison is just so cool as this
sea captain
and it just takes place on the english
seacoast be careful
there may be breakers ahead there's a
real escape that you get
from watching a black and white movie so
i would i would definitely put
the ghost of mrs muir on your list
you'll just be a puddle of a puddle of
love by the end of it
you bastard what did you do to my son i
am your son mom it's more of a modern
classic
uh but something that i recently
revisited
in quarantine was the movie big
with tom hanks
tom hanks plays 12 year old josh baskin
who finds himself in a grown-up body um
and it's one of my favorite movies from
when i was growing up and
like many people out there i'm stuck at
home with a five-year-old
and family we're looking for something
to watch as a family
and it was a real hit
go track down a little elaine may
picture
from the 80s ladies and gentlemen
ishtar is is this this is the oasis
does this look like an oasis to you yeah
look at the [ __ ] of the birds
are those vultures got dustin hoffman
and warren beatty in it and stuff
was once roundly considered the least
successful movie
in hollywood history they overspent and
they made no money at flop
dot dot um this movie is so worth
catching it's absolutely
hysterical
a little time capsule of course because
it takes place in the 80s
but man a movie worth watching that
like for a while a long time everyone
crapped on
[Music]
one of my favorite comedies of all time
is a film called car wash
it is directed by michael schultz and
because of his name a lot of people
don't know that michael schultz was a
black man he was a black director
he uh took the stone car wash was on its
surfaces just a kind of a comedy about
an inner city car wash and it it it
um it debuted at cannes and won a couple
of awards in 1977.
praise the lord praise the lord it stars
richard pryor
and the great bill duke and the legend
and icon ivan dixon
and it is um a snapshot of where
black america was at that time it's a
beautiful film with a lot to say
and it's funny and cool too
favorite comfort film for me is eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind
i i'm sorry i just said hi
jim carrey after a breakup with kate
winslet's character
um tries to erase her from his memories
you know it doesn't shy away from like
the big bold sad
feelings of a breakup as the movie goes
on
there's such humor in it and every time
i watch it it just
swells my heart the name's bond
james bond it's casino royale it's the
the daniel craig's first outing as as
james bond i just there's something
about that movie i just
absolutely love the action in it is so
great but the world is so great and
they're off in montenegro and
in tuxedos and they're playing card
games and people are drinking martinis
and eating caviar
and i just think it's the perfect escape
the acting's amazing in it
the opening sequence is one of the
greatest action sequences you'll ever
see and daniel craig is
is his bond as far as i'm concerned i
pick a recent movie man uh and that
would be
either avengers infinity uh war or
avengers end game
this is the fight of our lives if i got
nothing new to watch
i will make a meal and sit down and
start watching
end game all over again and stuff so
those marvel movies are my
they're my happy places my grandmother
used to refer to uh the soap opera she
would watch those are my stories
those marvel movies and story so that's
my comfort food those are the movies i
go to to feel embraced and warm
when he was out there fighting i was
here
[Music]
holding that bar day and night
you know a great movie for the times
that we're in um is a little known film
um in some circles it's called ashes and
embers
it is a film that traces the
homecoming of a black vietnam veteran it
came out in the 80s
um and it's talking about the black
soldiers who came back from vietnam
but it really is talking about the
condition of black communities
then and disparity in resources
and attention the lack of accountability
of police
this is a little scene film so if you do
watch this film you're watching a rare
jewel
down you know coleman barbara koppel's
documentary harlan county usa
barbara koppel spends um over a year
living with his coal miners and their
families
as they go through this strike
[Music]
and they're striking for living wages
and better working conditions
and i think re-watching it now was also
really
emotional because even though it's like
on such a smaller scale
than you know the black lives matter
movement that's happening right now
and it's not just like there's this end
and there's victory and
we did it but it's this ongoing struggle
another movie one could watch uh a
reflection of our times uh and
yet it was made 31 years ago spike lee's
do the right thing spike lees do the
right thing
it's as plain as dave they didn't have
to kill the boy
one of my all-time favorite films um
about many things about a day in the
life of bedford sivenson
in brooklyn but uh also
about uh race relations
on the hottest day in new york city
took on all these issues but they did in
such an honest
way where you really were trying to see
things from everybody's point of view
[Music]
it kind of comes out with this strange
understanding of each other at the end
it's really a great one to go back and
watch a movie that you could play today
and would feel like it was made this
year as well
just saw that actually it's such a great
movie it's amazing how so many of these
issues don't change but if you make the
movie the right way
in that right honest fair way that it's
timeless
right you can pick it up anytime
niche what do you think yeah there's so
much i went from highs to lows there i'm
sorry
i'm speechless i i heard you were
dancing in the background a little bit
during car wash